she is the pride of Mesa Arizona and
also now the entire United States of
America and why not she's the author of
chase your dreams we're all books are
sold and is in town for a part of what
we're gonna see this weekend at the Rose
Bowl the first of a five-game victory
tour for the US Women's National Team
great to see you Julie urge thanks for
having me
a pleasure Congrats thank you I am so
excited for you to be here it's not
funny because what you and your your
teammates did was so amazing what in the
world was it like to actually do it I'm
it was it seems like it was so long ago
now like I she's been really like
surreal right um but it was a really
special group for many reasons on the
field off the field I'm and 2015 was
amazing I loved that World Cup but this
one was so different in so many ways and
yeah it's been amazing and the support
has been amazing so I'm on cloud nine
yeah you should be and it was I was on
cloud nine we were all on cloud nine
watching so different how just because
you were you were younger it was your
first one in 2015 2015 I like didn't
think I was gonna play in the World Cup
and the office and I was just started
and was like so excited just and happy
to be there and didn't really like you
know my first big major tournament with
the national team and I was like well
this is great like we're in the finals
like this is happen all the time kind of
and you kind of just you know don't I
took it for granted I think I just was
really excited to be there and into the
19 I was like wow like four years I've
gone through a lot in my career through
adversity I think I just have a
different perspective and just kind of
every game I took it like slowly I made
sure I enjoyed every practice every meal
like everything I really just wanted to
soak it all in and how much of the
conversation about your team was seeping
into your bubble the conversations so
besides on the outside of everything I
know that we're but to be honest I
didn't really know anything and really
yeah so it's kind of nice to have that
bubble it's I mean we kind of created
ourselves starting on our send off
series right and so you don't really
know anything that's going on
all you know is you kind of only think
and talk and everything soccer and right
we have a job to do every time we go up
there and helps you stay focused so you
really didn't hear anything about your
those comments about your demeanor and
beating Thailand and anything course
you're gonna hear some things and
there's I mean how did it how did it get
passed along to the team just through q
and A's of I mean we have family there
in like obviously they're probably on as
well but then you have media there that
when you go through that asking
questions like oh did you hear this
whatever so then you kind of I mean
you're not gonna completely not hear
anything but I think now like I've been
long enough in my professional career to
be able to just have be able to carpet
my it's like I need to play and separate
so what what what of the I guess
conversations or criticisms that you
that you did here was the surprising to
you the most that was that where you
were like come on
probably the Thailand one to be honest I
would like you to be honest great okay
the Thailand since then why were you
surprised by that then I think in a
tournament factor like everything
matters on points to be able to get
through where you go um I mean it
everything goes up where you get out how
much days of rust you get I mean a
tournament is kind of that whole aspect
and you know we talk about kind of being
a team to push the sport forward and
continue to get better and wanting to
make women's soccer you know keep
pushing boundaries of what it can be and
you you kind of people are all eyes are
on you to do that and you know you play
every for like minutes World Cups every
four years so I was kind of more so
surprised before her like shocked that
we wanted to score as many goals as we
can regardless of who we were playing
like I didn't make the you know I didn't
choose who we got to play I didn't
choose right any of that but um you know
my job is to go there and and play I
sensed it you were laying down a calling
card for everybody that here we come
this is our first match everyone's
wondering okay certainly knowing that
France was going to be on your radar
screen not just as the country but as an
opponent that you were basically just
laying on a calling card
for everybody in the tournament to see I
am I think in every single game I mean
we were the lot I think we were the last
game of the tournament
I believe so we just sat and watched
games and I think the anticipation of we
couldn't wait to play you played on a
Tuesday it took it took I think it was
like we were like I'm pretty sure we
were the last game of the first like
rounds and so you're just you're err
anticipation is is insane
we were feeling really really good we
had really good send-off games the vibe
was really good with the team everyone
was like super excited so yeah I mean we
wanted to for sure we knew it wasn't
gonna be easy at all we had really hard
games coming in and I mean throughout
the entire tournament teams are very
good so I think regardless like we
prepared as if we prepare we prepared
the exact same whoever we play Julie or
it's here on the Rich Eisen show
two-time World Cup champion also gold
medalist you've got chase your dreams a
book right here what do you want people
to learn from this book right here Julie
that was really fun to write it's
basically I could reflect all through my
it's a preteen book so kind of for kids
to be able to learn a little bit more
about my journey kind of what I learned
throughout my career my journey in my
faith and yeah it's been it was really
cool to able to reflect through
everything of how my career's gone a lot
of people a lot of especially kids that
want to you know be my shoes only see me
during the game and don't really know
how I grew up through the sport or what
I've gone through or adversity how did
you grow up through the sport just so
many people I mean I'm one of them -
yeah I just showed you a picture of my
daughter a five year old who's just
getting into AYSO right now and I don't
know if you know her the exploits of the
electric bees of the local AYSO here so
how does one get from a red hot chili
pepper or an electric B to where you are
right now I mean a big one is just
cultivating your love for the game I
mean I had amazing coaches that I talked
in there about you know I wanted so much
I would just go out on my own
I wanted to just train as much as
possible and I was able to be challenged
and pushed in a healthy way to be able
to love it I think
being able to learn through adversity
when that hit as well it's probably a
big part of the book as well and kind of
about getting out of your comfort zone I
went to a new team and just trying to be
relatable to things that kids go through
especially in sports and yeah so it was
cool do girls females have to deal with
a you can't aspect that boys men don't
do that
well now we're trying to change that and
I felt like we've been able to
especially now especially with our team
as well it's been so amazing to be a
part of just this is my seventh year
with a national team and just the growth
of soccer and the states alone both men
and women but how many young girls want
to play as well just to even pay that to
be able for it to be a possibility
because when I grew up I didn't even
know if a professional league was gonna
be possible for me to play in right
unless I went overseas and now you have
the end of a cell here which is amazing
we're a fifth year with that correct
correct
uh-huh and so that's huge to be able to
see you in gross well I could I could be
a professional athlete here in my
country to be able to play in perform in
in obviously if you have one I'm based
in Chicago so young girls comm like you
can play in your own hometown and so I
think just the the possibilities and the
opportunities where that word our team
is trying to you know give is huge well
and then let's get to the the statement
from US soccer that came out just on
Wednesday crunching the numbers over the
last 10 years of the u.s. soccer and the
commitment towards the US Men's National
Team and u.s. women's national team and
I'll just read here from 2010 through
2018 US soccer says it paid women more
than the men what do you I know that you
are part of a lawsuit suing for equal
pay
what do you thought that was put out
yesterday Julliard maybe like very well
what I'm saying I well one I think for
us it's growing both on off the field
I think the direct comparison that
you're giving it's very we have a
different amount of games we play your
different payment strategy so it
I'm trying to like figure out the best
way it's basically we're doing
everything that we can to kind of show
and prove against them so I think of
course they're going to come out with a
statement but so it's would you say
fuzzy math is that what is that what
you're just I just want to you know
obviously this came out yesterday I'm
totally in rooting for you and you heard
the chance of equal pay from the fans
yes very rare that you hear fans
chanting the words equal pay from the
stands or anything like that yeah so
what do you think that US soccer is
working towards actually rectifying
something because they basically say the
things already rectified Julie no I mean
I think if there steps to getting there
I mean we this is a step obviously but
the lawsuit is just a step towards that
and they're going to get that and that's
what we're going towards I think I
didn't really quite understand it too
much reading it so I think I read it ten
times I couldn't understand yeah so I
think it just kind of keeps going
through it but I mean we know what we're
standing up for collectively so and the
men came out and supported you the US
Men's National Team yeah I said that so
that that that that okay I don't want to
put you on the string very diplomatic on
this front right now you try trying
Julie Ertz here on the Rich Eisen show I
know that the US Congress invited the
team to come and go to Washington DC is
that is that still in the plans best you
can tell or I I haven't even seen the
team everyone flies in today for the
game Pasadena so I have no idea I'm even
had time I even gone home yet so no
kidding I I don't even know the last
time you saw everyone was the parade in
the ESPYs that was based on the train
and I didn't even go to the ESPYs I
couldn't do another flight so I tapped
out okay I couldn't go hey you know you
know what your join my club since I left
ESPN 16 years ago you know my my my
ESPYs invitation was lost for 16
consecutive year so that the last time
you saw everybody was at the parade yeah
and then we've had our a couple end of a
cell game so I've seen a few here and
there but like okay I I don't even so is
this something that you're gonna be
discussing or something like that do you
yeah maybe I am again can I don't know
okay but so you're all getting together
at the Rose Bowl this this weekend right
Saturday okay okay and coach Ellis made
an announcement what I guess has been
privately discussed is that she's gonna
after this five friendly if you will
toward she's done as the coach of the US
Women's National Team I give you the
floor and coach Ellis and what she's
done for you guys
yeah I'm she's the most winningest coach
obviously and had a tremendous career
and I mean she's been two-time world
champion coach as well and I'm sure by
no means is is it and it's a difficult
job for sure I mean you're constantly in
the light as well so it kind of it came
as a surprise for me to me I did I mean
I guess when you're in the environment I
mean it's just so much that you're asked
you from but I mean she's been great and
I haven't really even talked to her I
just found out based at the same time no
Cuban everyone else did so do you have
any idea who might be in line for the
next easier I couldn't even give you AI
I literally like when you say you
haven't talked to anyone since like I
guess like if I came here tomorrow then
I probably would have better I haven't
really even talked to anyone I mean the
news just kind of came out yesterday was
it two days ago yeah pretty much yeah so
again I haven't even okay so the band's
the band's getting back together Rose
Bowl and I'll ask this question here cuz
the radio audience hadn't heard it
before you've never played in the Rose
Bowl before huh this is your first time
at the Rose right
yeah I watched Zak play in the Rose Bowl
in college and that's about it that's
about it yeah you know that was on TV oh
and you've never you've never played
there and okay yeah obviously the
Women's World Cup has some serious
history yeah right there as well Brandi
Chastain statues your statue that's
right they just they just gave her a
statue out in front of the Rose Bowl so
that's gonna be really special
tell me about the Zak the Earth's Family
Foundation obviously you and Zach have
created a foundation together yeah about
that what do you guys do it's been
amazing we basically you know raise
funds to be able to give kids
opportunities in sports and education
we've done work in Haiti where is that
went on a mission trip and kind of
started helps really jump start our
foundation but it's really based in the
Bay Area and Philly and it's just been
amazing it's it's so it's I think as our
careers go on and be able to see the
platform that that you have to be able
to give back and it's been extremely
rewarding totally different than
obviously what I'm used to in the sense
of you know training and being able to
kind of think outside of my comfort zone
and it's been it's been really fun and
extremely rewarding
so what's tougher do you think for you
to sit through a Super Bowl with the
game on the line or for him to sit
through a World Cup final with
everything on the line what do you
think's more difficult have you compared
notes harder to watch each other then
actually play it is you gotta be right
yeah because you I mean you just you
can't do anything you know like Oh most
athletes I know are control freaks yeah
you know and this is the ultimate out of
your control city understand rooting for
each other wanting the best for you no
yes I was sweating more in the Super
Bowl game than I was it was just I mean
it was just such an amazing game like
that was so cool one to be there but
like I mean you're playing the Patriots
in the fight like oh it was so crazy
yeah and it was like two degrees outside
oh yeah that was I was a viewers of two
degrees and then of course you know
we're watching exactly for the end zone
right here that was one of those crazy
moments where everyone thought is it
catch is it not at yeah it was right
there it was awesome what do you mean
you're writing that in that end zone
yeah so right where he caught it I was
like five seats up so I was like right
there where was he in in France was he
did similar front row frong I gotta go
up thinking with a big old hug and kiss
and yeah it was it was an amazing
tournament for so many reasons my family
was there yeah I just really enjoyed it
and and it's amazing how how much hum
fell how many folks traveled across the
Atlantic right to be there yeah yeah it
was um incredible I kept trying to
prepare myself okay you know it's gonna
feel like you're it's an away game like
you know it's not gonna be the same fans
crowd as it's gonna be in Canada but it
wasn't 2015 and it was incredible
including the final like I we it was a
home game in the final it was insane and
you get me then the band's getting back
together is everybody coming back
together the road
everybody's captain all 23 that's gonna
be amazing amazing I'm so excited oh you
must be yeah what was that parade like
canyoning heroes I mean that's what
astronauts when they come back from the
moon yet you know I mean that that's
what you got that's unbelievable
yeah it's it's so cool it's I'm however
I did notice there's a little less
ticker tape than usual but I think
that's because everyone's going digital
four years ago I was like I mean but
everyone had like confetti that they
would go I'm looking right here it looks
like a blizzard I'll be honest with you
I see oh but when people throwing out
the win yeah yeah yeah there it was like
a little bit like fear but um but it's
probably good recycling you know going
green in the head I should I shouldn't
be like you know promoting more right
paper to be thrown but um yeah I was
like wow everyone's a good digital but
the screams were ten times louder okay
that's fantastic
and used to wrap it all up here then
Julie arts here on the Rich Eisen show
you've written a book called chase your
dreams you know I get a motion when I
talk about my kids my daughter
especially I mean what you did what your
teammates did and putting it out there
for the whole country to see and root
for what's the message that you want
somebody like my five-year-old daughter
or anybody else out there listening like
with a with a young lady that's gonna
hopefully grow up into whatever her
dreams are what do you want everybody to
know based on what you and your
teammates just accomplished Julie won in
the soccer aspect I want girls to want
to take my you know my cleats there's
what I should say into my shoes and grow
woman soccer in the sports aspect alone
and continue to grow but on top of that
also stand up for what you believe as
well I think kind of obviously
collectively is like we there's so many
amazing opportunities that I was
presented from you know basically
chasing my dream of wanting to
so even if it's not that you want to do
soccer just believe in yourself and in
and and truly you can make a difference
but also in the in the soccer world I
also want to grow them and soccer so
much because I'm so grateful for the
opportunities that I've been given but
also of just what I've learned through
through sport as well which is
everything that I that I'm like about
like how how I can face adversity how I
look at challenges how much I love about
being a part of a team like I enjoy
those aspects of growing and pushing
myself as a as a person and asking
questions and getting out of my comfort
zone and I think I wouldn't have done
that if I if I didn't try and you know
have goals to set and try and get there
well Julie arts congratulations again
and another on another star and
obviously in your book chase your dreams
and then of course the family the
Earth's family foundation you can go to
Earth's Family Foundation org again a
ministry dedicated restoring hope and
opportunity to needy families at home
and abroad so you can donate there as
well you want to make a season
prediction on the Philadelphia Eagles
they go all the way
Super Bowls in Miami right you're still
being diplomatic I mean yeah oh no birds
just in Miami go to South Florida yeah
birds out birds to fly south in the
winter do good to see you Julie good to
see you thanks for coming on the show
Julie Earth's on both Twitter and
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app